don't blame me for josh and you bumping
uglies who wouldn't have been bumping
uglies if i didn't have clothing this
pregnancy thing is really getting my
nerves bouncing young y'all you
stressing me out
oh
yes
i'm pregnant again and by the time this
baby's here bentley will only be like 10
months i suspected it this time though
because either i'm hungry or i'm sick we
may be here a minute she's going to eat
all that
why aren't you hitting me because i'm
kind of fooling to be honest a little
nauseous
it's definitely not what me and josh
were planning for
hi ladies are we interested in getting
some dessert oh yes we're celebrating
the biggest thing you got on the menu
the king kong celebration of course
i mean so i operated are you did you
just like take like the at-home
pregnancy test or what well i mean i
took one of those too but i went to the
daughter's confirmed like it's like
early on though
now i'm worried about if i have a place
to stay or not you can move in with me i
got four bedrooms i told you in london
negative if you don't want to go to
mommy's nobody wants to go there with
you in your new damn booth
i'm very boring i'm very tired i'm
trying to call josh and tell him that i
told you to do
he's going to be you know he's already
stressed now he's been barely got her
damn money on a tight budget
well i mean if he was honest we would
already knew that
you want to talk about honesty
would i tell you first anyways you're
not even around all the time
i'm happy for pumpkin
but
what the hell was she thinking she's
gonna have two kids under the age of one
and she's gonna realize that she's gonna
need her mother you know so this may be
a good thing it may be able to work on
our relationship maybe able to spend
time with the girls be able to spend
time with the grandbabies
[Music]
[Music]
you got one of each which one do y'all
think blue
or pigment
blue or pink pumpkin
i don't know but i think this spoon is
big enough to smack your ass
[Music]